chào các bạn video này sẽ hướng dẫn các
bạn cách tạo văn bản dạng cột và như bên
trái màn hình thì đây là một cái văn bản
nó có ba cột gồm có số từ môn học và số
tiết và giữa ba cột này mỗi cột nó có
một cái định dạng riêng ví dụ số từ này
nó sẽ C giữa tại điểm này và môn học nó
cân trái tại điểm này và số tiết nó cân
giữa tại điểm này
và khoảng cách giữa các cái cột đy Nếu
chúng ta dùng phím táp Thông thường thì
nó là khoảng cách là 0 ph 5 inch tức là
1,2 mấy cm đấy Bây giờ là giữa số từ môn
học có thể sử dụng khoảng cách đó nhưng
mà từ môn học đến số tiết thì khoảng
cách đó nó nó lớn hơn 0,5 in vậy chúng
ta phải định nghĩa cái khoảng cách đó ha
Và bây giờ chúng ta sẽ thao tác
thì bước thứ nhất Chúng ta sẽ tạo bước
Tab trên cái thước đây là cái thước nà
Nếu chúng ta chưa có thước thì chúng ta
nhớ Bật lên bằng cách là vào thẻ view và
chọn ruler Nha vào thể view đây này À
chọn ruler này đây view ruler Nhớ bật
thước bằng cách này nha Thì lúc đó chúng
ta mới làm được Bây giờ á là trong cái
văn bản này có ba cột cột số từ là canh
trái
à Xin lỗi là cột số thứ từ là canh
giữa số tiếtc canh giữa môn hoặc là cáh
trái thì chúng ta sẽ dựa vào biểu tượng
táp đây này Đây chữ L này này là ký hiệu
của táp canh trái ha
và ở đây số thứ tự là canh giữa chúng ta
tạo táp C giữa thì chúng ta nhấp vào chữ
L này để chuyển từ tạp trái sang tạp
giữa nhấp vào nha này Đây nó ký hiệu này
là táp
giữa bây giờ chúng ta sẽ tạo táp giữa
cho cột số thứ tự thì chúng ta hình dung
nó đặt khoảng vị trí là 2 thì chúng ta
nhập vào trên Thược này Đây là vị trí
cân giữa cho số thử tử nha số tiết cũng
là căn giữa tức là căn giữa tại cái điểm
ha và chúng ta cũng tạo táp căn giữa tại
vị trí số 12 này cho cột số tiếtc 12 đây
chúng ta nhắc
đây như vậy trên thước là chúng ta có
được táp cân giữa tại vị trí số 2 và táp
cân giữa tại vị trí số 12 cho dòng đặt
con trỏ này
ha và Như vậy chúng ta đã tạo táp cho
hai cột số thứ tự và số tiết Còn bây giờ
môn học là táp canh trái chúng ta sẽ đặt
ở vị trí số 4 và đang đang hiện tại là
táp canh giữa muốn chuyển sang táp trái
thì chúng ta cứ nhắp chuột nhắp cho đến
khi nào nó xuất hiện chữ L khi dừng đây
ngay đây là tạp trái và khi xuất hiện
chữ L rồi thì chúng ta trỏ vào con số 4
trên thước nhắp chuột đây thì chúng ta
có tắp trái tại vị trí con số 4 Và bây
giờ chúng ta bắt đầu gõ dữ liệu vào
chúng ta nhấn Tab
gõ số thứ
tử tiếp tục nhấn
Tab phím táp là phím nằm góc trên bên
trái của bằng phím nằm ở ở dòng thứ ba
bên trái nha Nhấn Tab này à chúng ta gõ
vào là môn học và nhấn Tab chúng ta gõ
vào là số tiết
à Gõ xong dòng này chúng ta nhấn enter
xuống dòng và lưu ý rằng khi chúng ta
nhấn enter xuống dòng thì nó sẽ copy Tab
của dòng trên xuống cho nên chúng ta
không cần định nghĩa nữa chúng ta chỉ
việc nhấn Tab và chúng ta gõ thôi chúng
ta gõ tiếp 1 nhận Tab gọ
Windows Windows 11 nhấn Tab gõ vào số
tiết là
30 tương tự chúng ta nhấn enter nó lại
copy Tab của dòng trên xuống cho nên là
chúng ta không cần định nghĩa nữa chúng
ta nhấn tab để gõ 2 nhấn Tab gõ vào là
guộc phảy ba bo nhấn Tab gõ vào số tiết
là 50 rồi lại enter nhấn Tab gõ vào con
số 3 nhấn Tab gõ vào là mai
Microsoft
Excel nhấn Tab gõ vào là 40 Và cứ như
thế enter nhấn Tab gõ vào nội dung nhấn
Tab gõ vào mạng máy
tính và nhấn và
internet nhấn Tab gõ vào là 30 lại nhấn
enter rồi nhấn Tab Và cứ như thế chúng
ta gõ số thử từ 5 nhận Tab ứng dụng
ai
trong Microsoft Word à Microsoft
Office rồi lại nhấn Tab và gõ vào là 30
à cứ như thế chúng ta kết thúc cái phần
là sử dụng bước nhảy táp để tạo văn bản
dạng cột Tuy nhiên trong quá trình chúng
ta thao tác chúng ta cần phải có thể cần
phải hiệu chỉnh các cái vị trí của các
cái cột thì để hiệu chỉnh thì chúng ta
chọn các cái dòng và ví dụ số thự từ
chúng ta muốn dịt trái thì chúng ta nhắp
chuột vào biểu tượng kân giữa biểu tượng
táp kân giữa ở trên cái thước chúng ta
kéo qua trái các bạn quan sát số thứ từ
nó sẽ dịt trái tương tự như vậy môn học
nó sẽ dịch trái cái dịch trái này là do
chúng ta hiệu chỉnh văn bản mà thôi
chúng ta làm như thế nào cho nó phù hợp
với văn bản của mình và chúng ta trỏ
chuột vào biểu tượng táp chúng ta kéo
qua trái vậy xong và một vài trường hợp
khi chúng ta thao tác chúng ta chưa
quen thì chúng ta có thể nhắp nhiều lần
để đây và khi nhắp nhiều lần như thế là
nó tạo ra các bước táp khác nhau và
những bước táp này là thừa các bạn những
bước táp này là thừa vậy nếu thừa thì
làm sao thì chúng ta phải xóa và muốn
xóa thì nhắp chuột vào biểu tượng táp
trên thước Kéo xuống và nhả chuột vào ở
vị trí trắng của mng hình thao tác đó là
xóa Đấy và chúng ta quan sát là trên cái
thước bây giờ chỉ có là ba táp cầ dựa
cho số tự cân trái cho môn học và cân
giữa cho tổ tiết Và bây giờ chúng ta chỉ
việc là hi thực hiện một vài các định
dạng nữa là xong ví dụ cái này là canh
giữa in đậm lên hoặc số từ môn học số
tiết này chúng ta chuyển sang chữ hoa in
đậm lên và lưu lại xong và chúng ta kết
thúc cái việc là tạo văn bản dạng cột
bằng cách sử dụng bước nhảy táp V Xin
chào các bạn